hello everyone and welcome to another
very important game from round nine of
this year's Tata still Masters Edition
Vincent kheimer versus Notre Baker or
Vincent who already lost three games and
is currently without a single win is
looking for that first win so he can get
things going before the the tournament
ends uh and Abdul satrov without a
single loss he defeated Magnus Carlsen
he is currently leading the tournament
by a full point uh if he just continues
playing uh steadily not only Will he win
first place in the Tata still but he
will also grab like a lot of raiding
points he's already I can check I don't
want to trick you guys let me just check
um uh since he is currently on 2713
uh yeah he's up 20 uh up 23 that's uh
27-36 so he's currently at 27-36 on the
live ratings list which means that if he
does really well like he could he could
end the tournament with 27.50 perhaps
even which would be incredible but even
is a deadly opponent especially with the
white pieces let's see what happens in
this game so Vincent opens with C4 he
goes for the English opening C5 we have
Knight to F3 Knight to F6 Knight to C3
and Knight the C6 the Four Knights of
the English uh G3 preparing to think
into the light Square bishop and Ponte
E6 preparing to strike with D5 the
chapter G2 uh we have Pawn to D5 and now
C captures e captures and pawn to D4 so
the Rubenstein variation or the proc
variation uh all been known known before
we've transposed into the taraj defense
with Bishop to E7 and now uh there are
like 5 000 games that have read you this
position and pretty much always castles
this plate here and this has been a
popular line uh for over maybe even 30
to 40 years because sparov played this
uh move castles here Evancho played at
the Maximus played at one how played it
so uh it's it's a very old line and
everyone not Place castles here but
Vincent plays A3 it has been played only
once before and he uses it to try and uh
try and take Abu satrov out of any known
lines of theory and there is a game
where castles was played but here
another big just plays C4 and it is now
as of move 8 that we have a completely
new game which is very very exciting and
since the the light score Bishop is fee
and kettled if white plays E3 maybe even
ideas like Bishop to F5 to D3 are
possible
so we'll see how another big plays this
with Bishop to G sorry Bishop to G5
Castles by another back with Ponte E3
and now Bishop to F5 maybe hinting it at
Bishop to D3 but Vincent just plays
Knight to E5 for the moment the D3
square is nicely protected Knight to D7
and here we have some trades Knight
captures on D7 Queen captures and Ponte
H4 Vincent shows that he is not up for
for a boring game he wants to attack and
Bishop D3 is definitely an option
another Baker could play this and uh
well white cannot Castle but the white
can kick away the best Bishop H3 first
we kick away the queen to a less less
active square and let's say after a
queen 38 now Bishop to F1 and now we can
trade here captures captures the king
can come to G2 will be very safe and you
don't ever really want to capture on G5
to open up the H file for the white Rook
could be very dangerous uh so well it's
definitely an option
says he does not want to have any uh
such uh you know quick traits he just
goes back Bishop to E6 uh and okay here
we have Bishop captures and E7 Knight
captures on E7 and we have castles here
by Vincent with Bishop to H3 trading of
the light Square Bishops captures
captures and just Rook the E1 the queen
uh can't really do all that much by
herself here and the E4 is coming so
another bag brings the queen back and
now Pawn to H5 and uh if you play Pawn
to H6 here you stop white said man
advancement you have a pretty uh steady
game but uh he says that he wants to
have at least some fun so he plays Pawn
to F5
and okay uh The Rook is now coming to F6
then the H6 then he wants to win the dh5
pawn we have a four by Vincent uh Rook
to F6 and now Pawn to B3 busting open
this uh advancement here C capture some
B3 Queen capture some B3 and now Rook to
H6 going after the H6 pawn and just
Queen to B5 offering a queen trade since
Abdul satov knows that he's gonna win
the H5 Pawn uh he doesn't really mind
Rook to d8 and now Queen captures on D7
Rook captures and pawn to A5 so why did
uh Vincent do all this why did why did
he give up the the H5 Pawn well the
thing is the B7 Pawn is now a backward
spawn and uh he just wants to attack it
with the Rooks there's no way that black
will be able to prevent this okay Rook
captures an H5 but now just Rook e to B1
go putting pressure on the B7 Pawn we
have Rook to H6 and now Knight to a for
adding another Defender to B6 but also
preparing to go Knight C5 so Rook the C7
now preparing to double up on the C file
and now Rook the B5 doubling up on the B
file uh Rook H to C6 and now Rook a to
B1 going after the B7 Pawn we have
rooked the C1 with check captors
captures and now King to G2 and of
course Rogue back the C7 defending uh
but you can only defend it for one move
Vincent just plays Knight to C5 and now
he will win uh the the B7 Pawn is black
cannot defend it twice so upon the B6
this is how noderbeck decides to give
back the pawn captures captures captures
and now Rook to A7 looking for some
activity with the rook and now after all
is said and done uh one cannot help but
notice that uh Vincent has a one Pawn
Island and uh another back has two Pawn
Island so uh the the Deep on ndf Pawn
will be a little bit weak especially the
Deep one okay you can defend the F Pawn
with the with a move like G6 but the D5
uh will be an eternal weak yes and the
the base of a Vincent's Pawn chain is
the F2 Pawn as long as that pawn is
defended you don't have to worry about
um
uh about uh losing that pawn the only
way you could lose it is let's say Rook
day two is played and you somehow get
the Knight over to E4 or G4 but of
course uh that that's a lot of moves and
it's not easily achievable so Rook to D6
uh Vincent of course goes after the pawn
now the Knight cannot move G6 we have
knighted to D3 and now Rook to B7 and
here we have King the F3 uh if you go
after the the pawn right away it's
um I just Rook V5 you can defend the
pawn so it's not really all that
impressive so King to F3 first king to
F7 and now Knight the E5 with check King
G7 Knight to D3 and now Pawn to H6 and
here uh another Rebecca gives a a bit
too much perhaps to Vincent because now
Vincent can infiltrate with King to F4
but he doesn't he plays Knights to F4
the reason why King to F4 is so deadly
uh is because after Pawn to G5 you have
to go all the way to E5 and it seems
like you really don't want to be here uh
but the there really isn't any danger
The Rook cannot deliver a check the
Knight cannot move if you move the
Knight then this Pawn Falls this Pawn
Falls so while the king doesn't really
have any squares you you can't check the
white king and the king would be very
safe here so uh and and definitely a
winning position for Vincent but okay he
goes Knight to F4 he doesn't want to uh
go for it right away and oh this is move
39 uh Vincent can't spend all that much
time here he needs to reach move 40 and
gain time so here Rook the B5 defending
the pawn and now Knight to E6 check King
to F7 and Knight to C5 again uh The Rook
no longer defends the D5 Pawn so the
Knight again cannot move we have broke
the B2 now comes Knight to D3 just
circling around uh we have Rook the B3
and now Knight the E5 with check again
King to G7 and now Rook to D7 attacks
the Knight we have King to F6 only good
move uh and now Rook the ace 7 by
Vincent Rook to beat you and now Pawn to
G4 and here uh if you go for for
characters and captures then you just
resign resign here as black as the H6
Pawn is hanging and the Knight will be
hanging uh you cannot defend both so
here we have Pawn to G5 but now we have
King the G3 by Vincent uh the problem is
uh
this position is again winning but you
have to calculate very far away uh to
see why it is winning Rook the A6 wins
uh wins material by force I will show it
because it's a lot of fun King to G7 now
G captures on F5 Knight captures and now
Rook the G6 check okay King H7 the pawn
is defended now Rook F6 you go after the
Knight and once the Knight moves you go
Knight to G4 put pressure on the H6 pawn
and only now after H5 which is pretty
much the only way to save the pawn Rook
the H6 check forces the king to G8 and
now this Knight to F6 check nicely
connects with the D5 iPhone that's how
you win that pawn but okay after G5
Vincent went to King to G3 but now
another big gets Pawn to F4 check and
he's back in the game he captures G
captures and now you can't capture
because of Rook captures on F2 the more
material disappears on the board the
more sure anotherbeck is that he will be
able to draw this game King to F3 and
now Rook the D2 goes after the D4 Pawn
Rook the A6 check King to G7 defends the
pawn and now Rook to B6
uh there's no no good way to to take
care of this Pawn uh but also Vincent
wants to give it up to trade even more
material to go into a favorable end game
for him and there is really nothing
better than to capture this Pawn Rook
captures on D4 but now Vincent with the
tricky Rook B7 and now look at this you
have to defend the Knight King to F6 and
now Rook captures on E7 now you cannot
capture The Rook if you capture The Rook
just Knight the C6 check and uh Vincent
would be up a full night so instead
after Rook captures an E7 the only move
for anotherbeck Rook the E4 forces
Vincent to give back the material and
now Rook the H7 and now King captures on
E5 just winning back material we have
Rook captures on H6 and now Rook back to
B4 so two pawns each Rook the H5 check
King to D4 and now Rook the h8 uh
Vincent's uh Pawn structure is still
much much better the two connected pawns
are much stronger King to E5 and now
Rook the E8 with check King F6 rooked f8
with checking to G6 and now Rook to F5
going after the pawn but now another
back starts advancing his pass Pawn as
well Pawn to D4 we have rooked the D5
putting the Rook behind the pass Pawn as
one always should and King to F6 with
King to E4 and now we have king sorry
Pawn to D3 with check another tricky
move by anotherbeck saying that if you
capture my draw is all but insured if
King captures on D3 then there's this
very tricky Pawn to F3 move you go after
the pawn and after G5 check King to G6
King the E3 now goes after the F3 Pawn
but now Rook B3 check King F4 and now
the only move that saves the game for
another back would be king to H5 and
here you are very happy if King to F5
you don't care just Rook B4 and if Pawn
to G6 just King to H6 there's no way to
get promote this Pawn to a queen a rook
D6 you will keep the defending Rook to
B2 if King to F6 you just uh go Rook B5
and now after Pawn to G7 you play Rook
G5 and you don't care about anything
white does if Rook to D7 you just play
Rook to G6 now the king cannot go up the
board because of captures and if you go
down the board then still just captures
and even though white will win the pawn
it will be a very easy draw this is a
draw of course all of you know this so
after D3 check King to F3 by Vincent
says all right keep your Pawn for the
moment I will capture it on the next
move but uh I'm keeping everything
defended here King the E6 and only now
Rook captures on D3 and now King the E5
so now Vincent upper full Pawn can he
win this uh we have Rook the A3 uh Rook
the B5 uh another bag just has to wait
and see how Vincent will try to improve
his position King to G2 and now King to
F6 we have rooked the A8 and now Rook to
B3 cutting off the white king So Rook to
A5 and now we have a king to G6 we have
Rook to F5 uh going after the F4 pawn
and Rook to A3 now it seems that Vincent
can win the second Pawn as well but the
problem is uh the black kings just do
active King to G5 and once you move the
Rook you will play King to H4 and this
is a well-known drawn position there is
nothing white can do you cannot Advance
this Pawn you cannot Advance this Pawn
you cannot Advance the king forward
everything is covered uh if you go F4
then Rook to G3 check just wins the G4
pawn and uh of course if F3 which seems
like you should be able to play it then
Rook A2 check and once the king moves
King to G3 nicely infiltrates and if
white starts pushing you can even ignore
the pawn just King F3 or threat and
Checkmate and the uh the thread alone of
just checkmating in the white king will
be enough to get a draw as white will uh
forever be stuck checking the the black
king So Okay Rook day 3 was played with
F3 immediately by Vincent uh and now
Rook to A4 defending the Pawn King H3 we
have rooked the B4 and now King the H4
making some progress here Rook to A4 and
now Rook the f8 uh we have King to G7
attacking The Rook Rook to F5 and now
King to G6 another back happy with the
draw here not allowing the white king to
go any further Rook G5 check King to H7
and now Rook the H5 check King to G6 and
now Pawn to G5 wins and finds a way to
make progress here but now Rook to a one
we have rooked the H6 check King the F5
and now Rook the F6 check pushing the
black king back so the white king can go
up the board we have King the E5 and now
the problem is uh well not not a problem
the good thing for Vincent is that he is
completely winning here the problem is
he has to play a very precise move in
order to actually win this so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only move well sort of the only move
that wins the game well I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
brilliancy as you are a true Master of
the end game and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Rook
somewhere along the f file not F5 that
would be weird but F7 or f8 and the
point is uh and it was not played in the
game after Rook to fate uh it's uh it's
impossible uh for black to stop the
promotion of the g-pawn what I mean by
this is that after Rook H1 check let's
say King to G4 you play Rook to G1 check
King to H5 and now you have two options
continue checking or go after the pawn
we're gonna check both if Rook to G3
then you go King G6 Rook captures an F3
now you kick away the king both of these
squares are covered King to D5 or
wherever doesn't really matter King F5
that's the point now The Rook cannot go
behind the the pawn because a king
captures an F4 any Rook F1 now you play
Rook the E4 first and now after F3 you
will play Rook to F4 uh you have to make
everything uh precise otherwise you're
not going to be able to win this upon
the F2 Now Pawn to G6 and The Rook
cannot move here the king defends the
pawn as soon as the Rook moves you're
gonna win the pawn Advance the king and
promote your your Pawn to Victory or the
other way if you don't go after the G3
Pawn if you play Rook the H1 with check
uh still not a problem King to G6 Rook
to H3 again you can go after the pawn
but now Rook F5 check King to D6 now
Rook captures on F4 the pawns are
defended now you have two connected pass
pawns with a very active King again
completely winning for white however
after the skink the E5 move another back
tricked Vincent and Vincent played Rook
the B6 and this is the I I believe the
third or maybe even fourth time Vincent
um uh sort of uh what's the what's the
saying uh I don't know uh but uh that
does not take advantage of his winning
position and probably because he already
lost uh three games in this tournament
he probably just was making moves to
make sure he doesn't lose and then maybe
he just didn't go all that extra mile to
to find the winning ideas but who knows
uh now Rook to H1 check is a completely
different story King to G4 Rook to G1
check King to H5 and now Rook the G3 is
very much different because now you
don't have the option of uh of uh
checking the white you could play
something like Rook to B5 check but the
King goes up the board and it's not
enough so here Rook the B3 was played
defending the pawn but now King to F5
and here you have another big problem
Rook to H3 is now Checkmate you could
play something like G6 Rook to H3
Checkmate so yeah Vincent has to worry
about that as well Rook the B5 check
King to E6 Now Pawn to G6 managing to
advance the pass Pawn but not just Rook
captures on F3 and after Pawn to G7 Rook
to G3 this is not even close to what we
discussed in that line uh King stage six
defense the passport Now Pawn to F3 we
have rooked the B8 now preparing to win
the game but Rook the H3 with check now
you have to be very careful here it
seems like Pawn to F2 and everything is
perfectly fine like if you advance the
pawn we just give up the rook and then
Rook captures F1 Queen but this would
blunder the game for you Rook to f8 and
now white is completely winning and
games are are tricky like that you
always have to be ready so Rook to H3
with check King to G6 and it was uh in
this position and move 89 that the
players agree to a draw uh as there is
nothing more to be done here once a rook
to G3 is played for example you will you
will have to repeat otherwise you're
going to lose this Pawn Rook H3 or you
play King G5 Rook G3 King F4 and then we
just trade pawns and then of course
um it's it's a draw because both players
only have a king and the Rook so yeah
after King to G6 and move 89 uh Vincent
camera another
game which means that no quarterback
remains uh far far ahead ahead of
everyone else we can even check the
standings after round nine these are the
standings
another back leading the tournament half
a point ahead of Anish giri who win that
who won that brilliant game against Dean
lyren I mean Anisha defeated Ding and
Magnus and he is still not leading the
tournament that's how good another Beck
is playing in this event then with five
and a half points Wesley so Fabiano
caruana with Five Points Fabiano levonne
pregnant and Magnus Carlson uh would
foreign
have yet to play against one another so
uh that will probably be what it decides
the tournament or maybe not maybe they
just draw their games and you know win
all the other games against everyone
else uh still many games in the
tournament uh so we'll see what happens
but yeah a tough break for Vincent who
is still without a single win in this
tournament but another back on the other
hand is without a single loss in the a
tournament he had his chances but he
missed too many of them as they were
objectively winning but yeah no reubek
will defend if you don't play play it to
Perfection he will defend as you've seen
here so I once again hope you guys
enjoyed that I would like to thank Rob
Victor David Peterson and John Noonan
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual uh you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Tata steel until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day and sorry for a bit of a longer
video but all the end game magic had to
be revealed uh see you soon